اهلا بكم سيطرت الويه من الجيش الحر
وكتائب اسلاميه على سبعه قر في ريف حلب
تقع بين معامل الدفاع ببلده سفيره ومطار
حلب الدولي العمليه مكنت من قطع اخر خطوط
الامداد حول حلب وهي تاتي بعد ايام قليله
من رفض المعارضه السوريه المسلحه للاتفاق
الامريكي الروسي حول نزع الاسلحه
الكيميائيه السوريه والتاكيد على ضروره
مواصله محاربه النظام نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش من
زاويتين ما اهميه هذا التقدم العسكري في
سياق معركه حلب
المرتقبه وما تداعي هذا المعطى الميدانيه
على اي مفاوضات مقبله بشان الازمه
السوريه بدات غرفه عمليات حلب المركزيه
معركه في ريف حلب الشمالي والجنوبي
والغربي من اجل السيطره الكامله على
المدينه كما تتواصل المعارك في ريف حما
الشمالي وريف العاصمه دمشق بالتزامن مع
الجهود الغربيه لعقد مؤتمر جناب اثنين
والتخلص من السلاح الكيميائي للنظام طقا
للاتفاق الروسي الامريكي
الاخير الحرب وليس سواها يبدو ذلك خيار
المعارضه المسلحه في سوريا قبل وبعد
الاتفاق الامريكي الروسي غير المتوقع لدى
المقاتلين كلام رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
الحر سليم ادريس عن استمرار القتال حتى
اسقاط نظام الاسد يترجم على الارض بدات
غرفه عملي حلب المركزيه والتي تضم مجموعه
من الكتائب والويه معركه تحت اسم والعاديه
ضوحى تشمل المعركه ريف حلب الجنوبي والشرق
والغرب من اجل السيطره على مدينه حلب
بالكامل وطرق الامدادات للجيش النظامي
تفيد مصادر الناشطين بسيطره عناصر الجيش
الحر على سبع قرى في ريف حلب بين معامل
الدفاع في بلده سفيره ومطار حلب الدولي
حما جبهه مهمه مرشحه للاشتعال اكثر خلال
الايام المقبله يقول الناشطون ان المعارك
متواص منذ اكثر من ثلاثه ايام في ريف حم
الشمالي يضيف المصدر ذاته بسيطره
المقاتلين على عده حواجز تمهيدا لاقتحام
كرناز معارك الكر والفر لا تعرف هدنه في
ريف العاصمه دمشق وتحديدا داريا ومعظم
الشام تحضيرات ما بات يعرف بجنف اثنان
ومسار التخلص من الاسلحه الكيميائيه لنظام
الاسد لا تعني الكثير للمسلحين مسلحون
وعدوا بالسلاح في بدايه اغسطس الماضي ثم
بضربه عسكر
عقابيه ردا على استخدام نظام الاسد السلاح
الكيميائي في الغوطه ينتظر تنفيذ تلك
الوعود في وقت نجحت فيه روسيا بفرض
اولويات اخرى على حلفاء المعارضه هل سينجح
الحليف الغربي يوما في اقناع المعارضه
السياسيه والمسلحه بالقبول بتنازلات هي
حتى اللحظه من المحرمات لدى عده عناصر في
الجيش الحر واذا قبلت المعارضه السياسيه
الذهاب الى جنف تحت الضغط ما جدوى ذلك اذا
كان المسلحون في الداخل يرفضون التفاوض
على اي شيء لن يؤدي الى تخلي الاسد عن
السلطه هل المعارك المقبله جزء من
استراتيجيه التفاوض بفريق اقوى على الارض
ارض سوريا الان ساحه حرب لايدي لوجيات
عديده ومتناقض احيانا ومسرح لصراعات
بالوكاله بين دول قريبه وبعيده هل السلام
فيها ممكن وباي
ثمن معنا في هذه الحلقه من اسطنبول لؤي
مقداد المنسق السياسي والاعلامي للجيش
السوري الحر من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي يونس
عوده وهنا في الاستديو الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه العميد صفوه
الزيات اهلا بضيوفنا الثلاثه نبدا بالعميد
صفوت هنا صفوه الزيات هل ما يجري الان في
حلب هو بدايه تطور نوعي في سير المعارك
هناك اعتقد انه تطور نوعي كبير ان تقترب
من معامل الدفاع ان تحاول ان تحاصر معامل
الدفاع
والمفتشين الدوليين ربما تقترب اقدامهم من
الوصول الى الارض السوريه هذا يعني امر
كبير للغايه النظام كان يامل ان يصل احد
الى معامل الدفاع في السفيره في جنوب حلب
الا وهو يمتلك كل الارض التي حولها ويملك
الاذن بالدخول والخروج وربما يملك ايضا
القدره على المناوره باخراج وادخال اسلحه
مازال العالم حتى الان لم يقرر بعد ان كان
ما قدمه ل منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيماويه
على قدر من الصواب او الصحه او لا ولكن
الامر الاهم الان ان خطوط الامداد لمدينه
حلب من الجنوب تقطع تماما المعارضه
المسلحه منذ اكثر من عام ونصف قطعت طريق
دمشق حلب الطريق السريع الرئيسي الاول في
سوريا كان يعتمد تماما على انه يذهب من
منطقه اسمها السلميه ويتجه الى خناصر في
اقصى الشرق ثم ينطلق بعدها الى شمالا الى
معامل الدفاع ومنها الى مطار النيرب ومطار
حلب العسكري اليوم ان يسيطروا على اكثر من
سبع قرى وان يمتلكوا ناصيه التقدم منذ
اسبوعين ولدينا معارك ما بين كانت خناصر
والسفيره هم ربما يؤدون امرين يحكمون
ويطبقون الحصار على حلب من الجنوب ويقطعون
خطوط الامداد المتبقيه للنظام في هذه
المنطقه وينهار بالتالي النظام الدفاعي
كاملا لما تصوره النظام السوري انه قادر
على البقاء والاهم من هذا انه يبدو انهم
يتجهون الى حصار معامل الدفاع حيث تصنيع
الصواريخ البلسيه سكوت دي حيث تصنيع
الذخائر التقليديه وغير التقليديه حيث
هناك معامل للاسلحه الكيماويه والبيولوجيه
حتى الان نحن لا ندري هل سيكتفون بحصار
معامل الدفاع ام ان النظام سيصف بكل ما
يرمي بكل ما لديه محاوله معنى هذا ام قد
يكون هناك مؤشرا او تاشيرا او ربما ايماءه
من النظام الدولي ربما لتدخل المعارضه بعد
ذلك في حسابات تامين حركه المفتشين من
والى هذه المنطقه الحساسه للغايه نعم هو
الملفت ايضا سيد لؤي مقداد في اسطنبول
الملفت في هذه المره ان ما يجري يتم بغرفه
عمليات مشتركه فيها اطراف عديده ما كان
لهم ان يجتمعوا في السابق بل ان حتى بعضهم
حارب البعض الاخر في فتره من الفترات ما
اهميه
ذلك صح صحيح مساء الخير بدايه لك ولضيوفك
يعني بس ملاحظه صغيره على ما تفضل فيه
سياده العميد صفوه الزيات اللي انا شخصيا
كثير بحبه وبحترمه فقط بالجزء الاخير
المتعلق بعلاقه هذه العمليات بموضوع مساله
المفتشين ومساله مين تامينه واي متى بدهم
يجوا هذا الكلام نحن في الجيش السوري الحر
اعلنا تماما واعلن رئيس هيئه الاركان بكل
وضوح اننا غير معنيين بمهمه بعثه
المراقبين الدوليين اذا كان هناك مهمات
يعني يرغبوا بالمرور وتامينه وكذا نحن
نتعاون مع اي فريق دولي لكن ليس لدينا
اسلحه كيميائيه ليج يزورونا وليس لدينا
وليس ولسنا الجهه التي نرغب باست
باستلامها هذا الشان بين نظام بشار الاسد
والمجتمع الدولي ونحن بكل هي المؤامره ليس
لنا اي علاقه بيننا وبين بشار الاسد
البندقيه مساله الاتفاق الذي حصل في غرفه
عمليات حلب هو فعليا يعني يعني من اهم
الخطوات العمليه على الارض التي ترجم بها
مقاتل الجيش السوري الحر ردهم على
المؤامرات الدوليه وعلى الالعاب التي
ترتكب وبينما الشعب السوري يذبح وحدت جميع
الكتائب والويه في هذه الغرفه وكما شاهدت
اليوم البيان وهنا ايضا للتوضيح هل سيكتفي
الثوار ام لا كمان فكره اار اشار سياده
العميد هل سيكتفي الثوار او لا لا الخطط
واضحه الخطط الموضوعه تقول بتحرير كل ريف
حلب تمهيدا لتحرير حلب وتحرير المنطقه
الشماليه بكاملها ان شاء الله وبتخيل هذا
الموضوع ليس بصعب على الثوار اذا بقيوا
بهذه الهمه خلينا نحكي بالمعلومات شوي في
اخر 72 ساعه ما بين ريف حما وريف حلب
تدمير اكثر من 15 يه ثقيله للنظام بينها
12 دبابه ضرب كافه حواج جز النظام في ريف
حما الشرقي والغربي في حلب واليوم السيطره
على هذه القرى قطع خطوط خطوط الامداد
والتوصيل الايصال المحيطه بمطار النيرب
والاقتراب من مؤسسه معامل الدفاع واذا
فعليا استطاع الجيش السوري الحر تحرير
مؤسسه معامل الدفاع نحن نتكلم عن تخفيض ح
هذا المعمل ينتج ارقام تراوح مليون طلقه
روسيه في الاسبوع يعني سيكون هناك ضغط على
النظام بهذا الموضوع وهو مصدر رئيسي
لانتاج طلقات والذخيره للنظام ولتعديل
الاسلحه كما تفضل ضيفك سيكون انتصار انا
اعتقد سيكون انتصار هائل مساله اباط كل
هذا اسمحي اسمح لي فقط يعني اسمح لي فقط
النفس الذي تتحدثون به سيد لؤي مقداد وحتى
الذي تحدث به العميد صفوه الزيات يوحي
بان ما حصل هو
يعني مكسب كبير ل قواه المعارضه المسلحه
هنا في هذه الحاله سيد يونس عوده هل هل
تعتقد بان ما جرى يمكن ان يشكل فعلا هذا
المنحى الذي يجري الحديث عنه
الان لم اسمع ما دى في في الحديث بينكم
للاسف الصوت متقطع لكن يعني هو يعني باخت
باختصار ضيفان يعتبران بان ما جرى مكسب
كبير للمعارضه السوريه وقد يكون بدايه
لتحول نوعي في
سير المعارك في حلب
يعني في الواقع اذا كان صحيحا انه تم
الاستيلاء على قرى لا اعرف اهميه هذه
القرى في البعد الاستراتيجي للمعارك
الدائره ربما تكون قرى نائيه لا حراسه
عليها حتى مثل ما حصل مثلا في بلده معلوله
حيث كان هناك حاجز بسيط تم تفجيره ودخل
الى معلوله لكن فيما بعد حصلت المعارك لاع
لا اعرف اذا كانت الامور على هذا الشكل
تسير لكن في الواقع لا شك ان المسلحين
يحاولون تعزيز مواقعهم عشيه
اي الانعقاد المحتمل لمؤتمر جنيف اثنين
الذي سيقرر فعلا في الاجتماع المقبل في
نيويورك بين وزيري خارجيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا بكل الاحوال اذا
كان هذا صحيحا وبناء على كلام سابق وهو ما
اعلنه المسلحون بانهم تسلموا اسلحه فتاكه
واسلحه نوعيه فلا اعتقد ان هذه الاسلحه
النوعيه والفتاكه يمكن ان يكون مهمتها هذه
القرى طبعا الكل يحاول تعزيز مواقعه الان
لكن كما اعتقد ان المبادره حتى الان لا
تزال بيد الجيش السوري وهو يحاول اي ويعمل
مثلا في الامس تم السيطره على احياء واسعه
من حي برزي في اي ضواحي العاصمه ايضا في
الغوطه الشرقيه لا تزال هناك
اي يعني تقدم للجيش السوري في حماء في ريف
حماء اليوم اعلن عن استعاده السيطره على
بلدتين مهمتين كما قيل لكن في مسار
المعركه الخلاصه ان هناك محاوله تعزيز
موقع من اجل الوصول الى مؤتمر جنيف لكن
كما اعتقد ايضا ان الاشتباكات الدائره بين
جبهه النصره والجيش الحر ربما ايضا سيكون
لها داعيات اخرى ربما سيحصل هناك بعض
التغيير في الميدان ما يؤدي الى قبول من
في مؤتمر جنيف اثنين انا يعني اشرت الى
نقطه مهم مهمه سيد سيد عوده بعد اذنك اشرت
الى نقطه مهمه جدا وهي موضوع وصول امكانيه
وصول اسلحه نوعيه ل المعارضه هنا نسال سيد
لؤي مقداد الى اي مدى ما يجري في حلب حتى
نبقى في حلب مع اهميه بقيه التطورات بال
يعني عمليا هل هذا التقدم مرتبط بسلاح ما
جديد
وصلكم نعم بس بس في نقطه استاذ محمد بدك
تسمح لي يعني تقييم القريه كيف تكون مهمه
وكيف لا تكون مهمه يعني ما رح ادخل بتفصيل
السبع قرى اليوم وا وما مدى اهميتهم
الاستراتيجيه على الطرق الامداد والتوصيل
لكن دعني اقول بتوصيف ضيفك الكريم من
بيروت يعني هو اعتبر ان القريه التي
استعاد النظام السيطره عليها هي قريه مهمه
يعني هو عرفت كيف لما يحرر الجيش السوري
الحر قريه تصبح غير ذات اهميه ونائله وعلى
حدود الجابون بس عندما يحتل النظام اي
قريه او يستعيد السيطره عليها تصبح انتصار
استراتيجي مثل ما قال سيطر على شارعين
اليوم بب برزي يعني هذا انتصار جبار اما
تح سبع قره هذا الشي قره ئيه يعني انا لم
اقل هذا الكلام يعني سيدي لما تقول لما
تقول انه حاجز على باب
معلول انا اقول لا اعرف اذا كانت هذه
القرى في في البعد الاستراتيجي
بكل الاحوال اللواء الزيات يمكن
انش وترف انعم وتعرف ان القريه التي يطر
عليها النظام اليوم او استعاد السيطره
عليها مهمه يعني غريب حلب ما بتعرف بتعرف
استاذ سه الناس ما لم تقله انا لم اقل ان
من استعاده النظام هو قرى مهمه او ل بعد
استراتيجي لم اقل اسمح لي سيد عوده القضيه
ليست قضيه تقييم البعد الا لا اسمح لي حتى
نعيد نعيد الحوار في في سياق اسمح لي يا
سيد مقداد القضيه ليست قضيه الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لهذه القرى بعيدا عن هذه
المماحكات يعني نريد ان نعرف من السيد
مقداد ما اذا كان هذا التقدم مرتبط بوصول
اسلحه حتى نعيد السؤال الى نصابه لو سمح
لا يا سيدي نعم نعم يا سيدي لنتكلم بالبعد
التقني للمساله يعني كانت اخر فتره اخر
ثلاثه اسابيع الجميع يعلم ان ميليشيا
النظام وحزب الله والقتل الماجورين
التابعين لحزب الله وايران كانوا بحاله
ترقب للضربه العسكريه كان بشار الاسد قد
خبا طائراته ودباباته وصواريخه وكان ايضا
الجيش السوري الحر بحاله اعاده عمليه
تنظيميه يعني تشكيل غرف عمليات محاوله
الاستفاده من الموارد واستغلال الضربه
العسكريه المفترضه على النظام بافضل وضع
ممكن كان الطرفين في حاله ما يشبه حاله
الترقب حاله الهدوء الحذر الذي يسبق
العاصفه طبعا مع ابتعاد موضوع الضربه
العسكريه في الوقت الراهن على الاقل الجيش
السوري الحر استطاع استغلال هذه الفتره
لاعاده تنظيمه واستعاده تنظيم ورص صفوفه
وانشاء هذه الغرف العمليات التي كانت
منشاه اساسا حتى تستغل الضربه العسكريه
هناك ذخائر تاتي الى هيئه الاركان ليست
بالتاكيد الذخائر التي نرغبها وليست
الذخائر الكافيه ولي وليست الذخائر التي
نرغب باط للجبهات يعني هناك هناك ارات مر
هي مجرد ذخائر ام لديكم اسلحه جديده وصلت
هذه النقطه التي نريد ان تكون واضحه في
الذهن نحن سياستنا بهذا الموضوع انلا نقدم
خدمات مجانيه للنظام حول تحديد الاسلحه
التي تاتينا لا في صواريخ مضاده للدروع
هناك ذخائر للسلاح الموجود كميات قليله
حتى لا يفهم من كلامي اني اقول ان لدينا
وصلتنا ملايين الصواريخ ملايين ملايين
الاطم من الذخيره هذا الكلام غير صحيح
يعني نحن كنا نحضر لمعركه موازيه للضربه
العسكريه هذه الذخائر تقدم للجبهات حسب
الممكن وانا اقول لك اكثر من ذلك ان
الثوار في معظم الاحيان يعتمدون على
الغنائم انشا اللواء سليم ادريس اداره
عمليات مركزيه بيئه الاركان تعنى بالتخطيط
بات تذخير باستراتيجيه جديده وهي التذكير
على العمليات بمعنى ليس هناك ذخائر واسلحه
تعطى الى الكتائب وانه روحوا تصفر تصرفوا
بمعرفتكم لا الذخائر الان تعطى على
العمليات وحسب مراحل كل عمليه نحن ن
بعد اذنك هذا التطور هذا التطور الذي حصل
الان في في حلب بغض النظر عن تقدير القيمه
الاستراتيجيه ل القرى وهي مساله طويله
نريد ان نعرف الذي حصل ما هو تداعياته عن
اي تسويه نهائيه قد يتم بحثها في في
المستقبل فيما يتعلق بسوريا لنا عوده نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها التقدم العسكري
على الارض الذي حققته المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه في حلب والى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر
في ايه مفاوضات حول سوريا مستقبلا عميد
مصطفى
الزيات ضيفنا من بيروت السيد عوده صفوه
الزيات مره اخرى ضيفنا من بيروت سيد يونس
عوده ربط هذا التقدم بامكانيه ان ان تدخل
المعارضه
المفاوضات من منطلق قوه بينما السيد لؤي
مقداد يقول نحن غير معنيين لا بجناب اثين
ولا
بالاتفاق الخاص بالسلاح الكيميائي هل يمكن
ان نعزل ما يجري عن حسابات سياسيه
مستقبليه لا على الاطلاق نحن سندخل جنف
والاوراق التي ستقدم هي الاوراق التي على
الارض بمعنى ان المعارضه المسلحه عندما
تصل الى ربما الى انجاز كبير قد يكون وهو
السيطره على مدينه حلب بالكامل وتواجد
الحكومه المؤقته بها هذا رمز كبير لان
اكبر مدينه اكبر مدينه على المستوى
السكاني والاقتصادي والاجتماعي وحتى
بمعناها مفهومها انها جزء من التركيبه
الديموغرافيه المتكامله التي تؤشر لسوريا
الحديثه ان تصبح في هذه الصور هذا امر
كبير ان يتواجد الثوار ايضا في معادله
تامين ارتال المفتشين الدوليين الذي يبدو
انها قصه ستكون طويله وان يدخلوا في
عمليات التامين هذا دليل على انهم يتواجد
على الارض القتال الذي يتم على مدار
الساعه في دمشق هذا امر هام قطع خطوط
الامداد القتال الان في حماه والوصول الى
السيطره على شبه مناطق في الريف الشمالي
والشمال الغربي لحماه هذه ولكن اسمح لي
حضره العميد هذا من باب الكر والفر الذي
تعودنا عليه طوال الاشهر الماضيه ما لم
يحصل تطور درامي نوعي كبير بمعنى سقوط
مدينه حلب سقوط مدينه
ن نحن نتح عن كتالي منب ان تحمل هذه
التطورات اك تحتم للا نختلف ولكن على
الاقل النهارده هم رقم في المعادله على
الاقل لم يعدوا هء المجموعه من الافراد
الذين كانوا امام المسجد العمري في بدء
الثوره وتكلموا عن مجموعه من المتمردين او
الارهابيين يقاتلون في حلب يسيطرون على
حلب الان يحاصرون معامل الدفاع الان في
قلب دمشق في برزه وفي القابون وفيو جبر
هذا جيد الان في درعا يقتحمون اخر مناطق
في درع المحطه هذا جيد في كل هذه الامور
سيكون هناك مصاري متوازيين مسار عمل سياسي
ومسار شيئا ما يتحقق على الارض ويتحقق نعم
على ذكر الشيء ما هذا سيد يون
سعوده ما يجري الان في حلب اشرت قبل قليل
الى انه مرتبط بما هو اتي من من مفاوضات
سياسيه هل هذا ربما ما
يجعل السلطات في سوريا احرس ما تكون على
اجهاض مثل هذا الامر لانه اذا بدات
المفاوضات على افتراض ان تبدا والجيش
السوري الحر مثلا مسيطر بالكامل على حلب
هذا يعني معطى مختلف يغير الصوره بالكامل
ربما يعني هذه فرضيه ربما غير
واقعيه يمكن ان لا يسيطر بالمطلق وربما
يعاود الجيش السور وربما يعاود الجيش
السوري ايضا هجوما مضادا
وينهي هذه الحاله لكن عندما يقرر وهذا
اصبح معروفا ولا جدال فيه اذا قرر
الامريكيون والروس ان مؤتمر جنيب في هذا
اليوم يتم الاتفاق على من سيحضر هذا
الاجتماع ومن ثم يؤتى بمن يحضر طبعا
الدوله السوريه ستكون وهي رحبت دوما لكن
من من القوى المعارضه ه هذه المشكله طبعا
النصره لن تكون متمثله اطلاقا
وهذا قرار يبدو انه ليس فقط على مستوى
الدوله السوريه بل على المستوى العالمي
اما من الاطراف العامله على الارض فلا
اعتقد ان هناك الا بضعه
اي يعني ممثلين يمكن ان يكونوا وايضا من
المعارضه الخارجيه المعارضه
الصوتيه المتمثله بما يسمى بالائتلاف ها
هذا هؤلاء يعني يستدعون للجلوس ربما
يستدعون وربما لا وطبعا هناك هيئه تنسيق
في سوريا ايضا ستكون حاضره
لكن اولئك الذين على الارض ربما سيحصل
معهم كما ح اسمحلي سيد ع على اي اساس على
اي
اسج تكون في الاستماع الد هذا
الت استاذ محمد اذا
بتد انا اعتقد ان
هؤلاء على الارض سيكونون من الضحايا وانا
ايضا ضحيه من الضحايا لان انا بحاول اطرح
سؤال وحضرتك مش عارف هل تسمعني ام
لا تسمعني سيد
عوده هو ايضا ضحيه لا يسمع السؤال اسال في
هذه الحاله سيد في الحقيقه الان سمعتك
الان
سمعتك بشكل سريع على اي اساس تعتقد ان هذا
الطرف قد لا يدعى بينما هيئه التنسيق مثلا
تعتبر انها س ستدعى باي معايير انت تحدد
من سيحضر علي ملوك علي مملوك بده يحط
الاسماء رستوم غزالي بده يحط الاسماء لانه
عرفت بنقل اياه هون نعم لنستمع الجواب سيد
عوده بسرعه حتى نعود اليك سيد
مقداد لا ليك انا مش عميل صغير مثلك يا
حبيبي لا ارجو ارجوك ارجوك سيد عوده خلي
كلامك معاي لو سمحت انا اعتقد ان الذي
يتمثل الذي يتمثل الذي يتمثل في المؤتمرات
هم الاشخاص الجديون وليس الذين
يعملون بتعليمات خارجيه انا اعتقد ان
هؤلاء الذين يمكن ان يتفق عليهم وليس
الذين يفرضون بكل الاحوال الولايات
المتحده ستحدد من سيحضر مما يسمى
بالمعارضه في هذه الحاله سيد لؤي مقداد هل
ما يجري الان على الارض هي محاوله لاطراف
عسكريه اثبات نفسها ووزنها الميداني ليس
بالضروره تمهيدا لحضور ولكن تثبيت على
انها رقم يجب ان يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار في
ايه ترتيبات تجري هنا او
هناك يا سيدي طبعا هي رقم يؤخذ بالاعتبار
يعني هي رقم وقد اثبتته كل الفتره الماضيه
اما اللي مانه رقم هو اللي راح سيرجي
لافروف وقع عنه اتفاق جنيف وسلم الكيماوي
هو قاعد بالقصر مع اسما هذا اللي مانه رقم
يا سيدي بكل الاحوال يعني اذا قلنا ان
جنيف ستكون بين طرف ممثل ب بشار الاسد او
ما سماه الدوله السوريه وهو يعني به حزب
الله وايران وميليشيا الصدر ولواء ابو
الفضل العباس هذه الاطراف العامله على
الارض الاطراف الاجنبيه والتي بالنيابه
عنها تقوم ايران وروسيا بالتفاوض مع
الولايات المتحده انا اعتقد ان من سماه
بالمعارض
الوانه للشعب السوري به ا به اهانه للشعب
السوري عندما عندما يقول ان هناك معارضه
صوتيه وهناك معارضه وصفها بهيئه تنسيق
وهذا الكلام نحن نحترم الجميع لكن
بالنتيجه هناك كيانات رسميه شرعيه تمثل
الثوره السوريه الائتلاف الوطني اتفقنا او
اختلفنا معه في مفاصل عمله لكن هو كيان
سياسي منظل الشرعيه سياسيه للثوره السوريه
باعتراف 120 دوله شايلينه من على الخارطه
مثل وليد المعلم ما في مشكل لكن هذه الجات
الدوليه اعترفت بهم هيئه الاركان ممثله
بشخص رئيسها اللواء سليم ادريس اللي رح
يكون بكره بزياره الى فرنسا وهناك الاسبوع
القادم زياره الى واشنطن لرئيس الائتلاف
برفقه وفد قد يكون مشترك مع الاركان سيجري
الاتفاق لموضوع جنيف ومن سيكون حاضرا ومن
للا يكون حاضرا انا اعتقد هناك مظلتين
شرعيتين مظله عسكريه ومظله سياسيه للثوره
السوريه مع كل تقصير هما تقصير المظل
التين الاركان بحكم الموارد والائتلاف
بحكم بعض الخلافات لكن هذه مظلات تستحق
الاحترام وهي تمثل الشعب السوري ولا يحق
لاحد وخصوصا اذا لم يكن سوري اهانه هؤلاء
الاشخاص لانهم يمثلون جزء من الشعب السوري
ولو حتى نسبته 1% شكرا لك شكرا لك سيد لؤي
مقداد المنسق السياسي والاعلامي للجيش
السوري الحر كنت معنا من اسطبول شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي اللبناني
يون سعوده وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا هنا في
الاستديو الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه العميد صفوه
الزي بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في
امان
الله